why decide to write a book titled
contagion myth
through understanding the history of
contagion we
understand really how we got to the
present day but then i had an experience
that i would say it changed my life
what are your thoughts with covet and
coronavirus are you someone that trusts
taking a vaccine or there's no way in
the world you're going to touch a
vaccine
all of the tasks are meaningless all of
the numbers
are meaningless there is no possible way
that hovid19 is caused by this
coronavirus
how do i get sick i can't give my germ
to somebody else is that kind of what
you're saying
no that's not what i'm saying what it
proves is you can't give
sickness to somebody else little bit
complicated but i'm trying to up my
intelligence so keep going if you look
at a cookbook from 1920
butter lard and eggs nobody had heart
attacks
i want to live a long time dr tom okay
what foods do you absolutely avoid
if it has a label don't eat it any
linkage between
vertigo and dizziness and 5g towers
being put up in different places
it seems a little crazy to keep doing
that over and over again
and expect that we're going to get away
with it testosterone
replacement what are your thoughts on
that you're eating crappy food your
joints are deteriorating
your body is lowering the testosterone
to keep you from hurting yourself is
there a natural
cialis or viagra the native americans
had a very good formula for this
where do i get some high quality buffalo
balls
i'm gonna not have you make babies cause
you're
too dumb to do that
so my guest today is dr tom cowan
who uh he's written many different books
in the past before but he's got a new
one coming out as well uh in the past he
wrote a book called
human heart and a cosmic heart he also
wrote vaccine autoimmunity
also cancer and the new biology of water
and a new book that's coming out called
contagion myth
he got his undergrad at duke university
in 77 then he went to the peace corps
for two years
then became a doctor going to michigan
state university so with that being said
dr tom
cowan thank you so much for being a
guest on vapetainment
thank you patrick it's great to talk to
you and meet you
yes feeling is mutual so you know
why why decide to write a book titled
contagion myth
um that's a good question because i i
have been thinking about this subject
probably for
35 years and i was hoping not to write
about it because
it's so controversial and i was hoping i
uh had was done writing controversial
books
but it just became clear to me that the
what i was seeing was so uh unmatched up
with what i was hearing in the
scientific
community that i felt compelled to
really look at this subject
and really educate myself and their and
what i found felt like it needed to be
written about
so what do you write about in there that
others would consider controversial
yeah that's a good question and i think
the real answer to that question
would have to go through the history of
what i found and
i i hope we can talk about that because
i think
through understanding the history of
contagion
uh we understand really how we got to
the present day
so if you're okay with that i'd like to
describe uh the history of how we got
into this
so can i call you tom during the
interview are you comfortable so tom
uh uh you know i have four outcomes of
this interview four outcomes i have in
this interview based on the research i
did on you on the topics i saw you
talking about in
interviews one is uh um heart
and the reason why i want to talk to you
about heart you've spoken about that a
lot and
for someone who's in business and it's a
very very high pressure type of a
situation
you always hear about stress and
pressure linked to heart so i'd be
curious to know what your thoughts are
on that
since you've written about it and spoken
about it that doesn't have to be the
first one i'd like to talk to you about
the
germ theory and what we've been told
over our lives you know
how we get germs whether it's
respiratory or coughing and be careful
and you have different point of view on
that so i want to hear that as well
and then vaccine and obviously contagion
myth and some of them have to do with
each other so
i think it's probably very helpful for
the viewer to get an idea about
the 35 years of research that you were
talking about that got you to where you
are today to want to write that book
contagion myth
so if you'd like to take the lead on
that that'd be great
so as far as my background um so i agree
you know
i i go to uh duke and i
had the feeling that i should be a
doctor but sort of didn't like the whole
idea i didn't like a lot of things that
i saw
and so when i graduated there my idea
was to try to do anything i could
besides being a doctor
so i joined the peace corps and taught
gardening and
interestingly and i i often say i may be
the only person on earth who can say
this
i'm living in a mud hut in swaziland and
i was given the books about weston price
and rudolph steiner and what they
thought about nutrition
and basically medicine and it's
as if a light went off to me saying
the kind of doctor i didn't want to be
was not the only kind of doctor there
was
and that there were people who were
linking
food to health and there were linked
people linking
other ways of doing medicine and other
ways of seeing the human being
which i had no idea about so then i go
to medical school
and i wanted to be a family doctor i
joined a family practice residency
and then uh i was already you know
interested in natural healing and food
and i knew
something about vaccines but then i had
you know an experience that i would say
in a way changed my life which is about
two months into my
first year residency i was in a clinic
and there was a
child at their second dpt shot
where severely injured to the point
where they i don't think they survived
and you know that was course was
shocking to all of us because it was
very clear the baby was perfectly fine
when he went in
and then had this severe brain injury
which was to the dpt
shot which was actually happening a fair
amount at the time
and i said to myself i did not go into
medicine to hurt babies
and but really what i saw was that
that really disturbed me besides the
fact that we had just heard a baby
was that the doctors essentially lied to
the parents
and said there was no way this could be
a vaccine reaction
even though it was very clear that the
package insert which i
showed them said that this could be a
vaccine reaction
uh the other thing they did which was
equally disturbing to me
is they didn't report this to anybody
and so
essentially from a normal statistical
point of view you know the
people who are collecting statistics
this never happened
and then i saw this over and over again
and i started to realize
that the reporting system we have and
the
way we communicate to patients was just
really flawed this of course did not ind
endear me to my teachers and it became
very clear after my year in residency
when i got my license
that you know i just couldn't be part of
this because i refused to
vaccinate uh the children in our clinic
and then i ended up spending the last 37
years with a practice a lot of it in the
first
20 was based on seeing children
basically all of whom were unvaccinated
many of whom got all the typical
childhood illnesses
and i essentially was tasked or
tasked myself with how do i
how do i treat these children because
none of my patients would vaccinate
i wouldn't vaccinate i probably gave
seven
tetanus shots in my entire career and
you know essentially regret every one of
those because i didn't know
what i really needed to know about
tetanus
and so i had to learn how to treat these
children
what i found over and there's very few
doctors who have that experience
i mean that is my background now i can
tell you that after 35 years
as far as i know i never had one bad
outcome from a so-called vaccinatable
disease
i never lost a child to measles chicken
pox whooping cough
i saw hundreds maybe thousands of these
and everybody was fine and the other
thing i saw
is very few of my patients
actually had chronic disease so i
i actually was not very good at treating
asthma and eczema
and you know add because none of my
patients had them
now i did get patients from other
practices you know they
heard tom is good at treating you know
chronic disease and they were all
vaccinated children
and they came to me for help with their
asthma or eczema or
add or whatever it was but they weren't
my
patients originally and so what i was
seeing
was two different groups of children the
one who were
essentially perfectly healthy you know i
used to joke that
i would sometimes because i had three
children at the time too i would
see these children and their parents at
the playground and they would say
oh there's my doctor and i would think
to myself
wait a minute i don't i don't think i've
seen this child in three years
and and and you know we had a good time
how are you i'm fine you know playing in
the dirt and
that was my experience now
i think some people would say i mean
that's sort of anecdotal you know that's
not a
blind studies but i had to learn
how to practice medicine in that context
and so i developed a huge repertoire of
what works because i couldn't afford to
be doing things that wouldn't work and
again as far as i know i've had no bad
outcomes
now i'm retired so apparently i got
through the whole thing and that's my
story
so so now let me ask you while you're
going through this who was your
inspiration because
for me when i see doctors who eventually
get to your
uh position where they look at the data
and the data says over the past 50 years
rates of autoimmunity and chronic
disease have exploded currently one in
two and a half american children
has an allergy one in 11 has asthma one
in 13
have a severe food allergies and one in
36 are autistic or have autism right
you have based on the interviews i'm not
in your world i'm not a doctor i'm not
practicing but i've interviewed many in
your world and i've interviewed a lot of
people that eventually become
you know a questioning vaccine
does it seem like there are two types of
doctors those that become rebellious
and they end up questioning everything
and say i don't know if this is the
right way of doing things
and those who just kind of follow the
guidelines follow the rules follow
everything they tell them to do and it
becomes a transactional type of a doctor
but those who push the envelope a little
bit
they tend to have an inspiration
something inspired them to do that what
was your
source of inspiration uh you know that's
also a great question
and my particular answer to that
was you know so i was pretty young too i
was you know
late 20s and and so what i did was
try to seek out people uh who you know
it's an interesting quote from
carrie mullis who we may talk about
later but
that there must be some wise men out
there who could guide me
and so i looked and i looked in
homeopathy i looked in herbal medicine i
looked in chinese medicine i looked in
anthroposophical medicine and you know a
lot of those
i i would say i'm fluent in you know i
know how to do homeopathy i know how to
do herbalism i know how to do nutrition
i know how to do anthroposophical
medicine but
frankly my experience was none of them
really worked
and it was very you know to some it may
be disillusioning
but you know to me it's it's like
i i almost have no dog in the fight
like i'm not allied to conventional
thinking
anthropological thinking homeopathy
whatever
i have a child in front of me who's got
chicken pox
i need them to be fine and go on their
way
and be you know normal and i got to
figure out how to do it
and however i do that that's not going
to hurt them
that's what i did and so essentially
i had to come up with my own system of
doing medicine
and that's what i did and that's why i
wrote books
your own system when when you did come
out with your new systems would
you did it ever get you in trouble did
you ever have any issues with the board
did they ever come out and say hey
uh dr cowan you can't be doing that did
you have any kind of experiences like
that with the board
yeah a little bit but that's just normal
i mean okay
that's just how it goes so in your world
that's normal that's not a big deal
no okay that's that's what happens very
okay interesting keep in mind not all of
us are doctors and have the kind of
experience that you have who
have study which you've studied so for
some of us you know in the financial
industry or in the business industry you
mix things up or you come up with
something creative
you have regulators that could come out
and say you can't sell a product like
that you can't say this i'm curious to
know
how uh uh you are regulated by the
guidelines that you have so
now now let's go back to the book
contagion myth which i asked you i said
what was the purpose of re you know
writing this book you said
you know you kind of need to know my
background to know why i wrote this book
now that we know your background what
was your inspiration to want to write
that book
uh basically because i looked through
the history of contagion and if you
would permit me i'd love to share what i
found out with your listeners
please uh so so what are we talking
about here we're talking about
that the the normal observation that
you know a certain person gets sick in a
certain way
let's say a cold or a flu or that and
then somebody else in their
vicinity or their family or whatever
gets sick in the same way
and one says something was passed
between the first person
and another person and this is a very
normal clear observation we've all had
it
and in fact interestingly you know it
was first described
at least 2 000 years ago by the ancient
greeks
they said there's something that's
passed between people
we don't know what it is you know they
thought the spirits or who knows what
they couldn't see anything and and then
they thought
there must be something contagious and
we go then for about
1800 years without being able to find
the agent
now i would point out that this sort of
western science western medicine
is not the only stream of thought going
on in those 2000 years right there's
chinese medicine there's probably
traditional iranian medicine there's
native american medicine there's
ayurvedic medicine
these are very old successful medical
systems
and what you find is none of them
thought diseases were contagious
none of them there is no concept in
chinese medicine
that something unseen passes from one
person to another
and in no other system did that exist
now of course that doesn't mean it's
true you know they could have all been
wrong but when i looked into it i
thought that was sort of
interesting so then we get to around the
1800s and now we're really talking about
and there was what i call the first
eureka moment
right so we're thinking one person is
sick
another person gets sick there must be
something spread
and that observation is what's called
epidemiological
observation now i just want to point out
something here
that this contagion theory was applied
to
to the following disease there was a
bunch of
sailors who got sick and one sailor
after another got sick
and they their teeth fell out and then
they went into heart failure and died
and this happened in the thousands and
thousands of people
and it was usually one ship after
another and for a hundred years they
said this must be contagious and then
somebody ate a lime and the whole thing
went away because it turns out it was
scurvy
and the reason i point that out is
epidemiological
observations like this person got sick
and then somebody
else got sick is well accepted in
medicine that is not how we prove
causation and you hear this now
all the time well a lot of people in one
place got sick so it must be a virus
well
a lot you know they blew a bomb off in
hiroshima a lot of people got sick and
nobody thinks that was a virus
or they'll say if it spreads from one
place to another that proves it's a
virus
so i'm sure you remember chernobyl there
was a nuclear accident a lot of people
died
it started spreading into eastern europe
and then western europe a lot of people
got sick
and as far as i could tell that's no
evidence that that was a virus
in other words the the the idea that
a lot of people in iran or turkey or
spain
or the nursing home or the cruise ship
or the whatever
got sick you know my aunt bessie went to
a party
those are epidemiological observations
the purpose of which is to generate
theories which can be
tested for causation period
and i would agree agree a hundred
percent that we had enough evidence
with contagion that we should
investigate
for an infectious cause or an unseen
agent
now that's what louis pasteur famously
did
he said uh there's all these people and
in fact what he used was the case of
sheep and said
there's all these sheep getting sick
one sheep after another sometimes the
people who are handling the sheep got
sick
so there must be something uh that's
past
they then it had an invented the
microscope
so the first eureka moment in history
then
is they could see this bacteria under
the microscope and they saw the bacteria
in the sheep
and they saw it in the in the next sheep
who got sick
end of story that's what caused the
sheep to get sick called anthrax
and but here's what happened then uh
pasteur isolated the anthrax bacteria
from the sheep
right so he took them out yeah and he
gave them to
other sheep and none of them got sick
none of the people got sick
now here's the way i think people should
understand this
imagine you have a cow and you don't
feed the cow
proper food which is grass right you
feed it
cardboard and dead cow parts and you
know
and you soak it in glyphosate and tick
poisons etc
all that stuff comes out in the milk now
then somebody drinks the milk and gets
sick that's contagion right
and then you look in the milk and you
see a bacteria called listeria
and you say okay that may be the
causative agent
and then you look in the stool of the
person and they also have listeria
end of story and so the listeria you
drank listeria it made you sick
now unfortunately though or maybe
fortunately there's another explanation
for that
which is the cow was sick the milk the
poisons went into the milk
the role of bacteria in nature is to
biodegrade poisons right
if you have a compost pile and you put
dead squirrels in it you'll get
bacteria to eat the squirrels if you
have a pond and you put poisons in it
you get
algae growth that eat the poisons if you
have a forest and you cut the trees down
the algae and the fungus and the
bacteria eat the dead trees
that's called biology that's called
bioremediation
so how do you know that the listeria
isn't there to to digest the poisons in
the milk so we have two very
clear explanations for what may have
happened right
it's either the bacteria or it's the
poison
and the bacteria are not causing
anything they're just helping you out by
eating the poisons
as they do in nature now what i tell
people is
this is what pasteur and his colleagues
did for 40 years because
there is a very simple way to sort this
out
all you have to do is isolate the
listeria from the milk
right you can't give them all the milk
because then you don't know if the
poison's in it
isolate the listeria give that to a
bunch of animals
see what happens that's what they did
for 40 years
and as far as i can tell from the
medical literature
no animal or person gets sick
now it must be the milk yeah
so when when i when i was looking at the
difference between him and dr
jon snow uh uh and i'm sure you studied
dr jon snow as well where he had a
a different angle that he he had what
was the difference between the two of
them
between dr john snow and uh and pasteur
yeah i i don't know who jon snow is you
mean beauchamp
not beau sham dr jon snow's also during
the same time as 1850s because i know uh
pasteur died 1895. during the same time
you know
snow was linking everything to water so
i know you're specifically isolating
water
milk right now because of pasteurization
and you know most of us just say
pasteurization and we don't even know
where it comes from some of us know it
comes from
the name pastor but he was also talking
about how a lot of the viruses were
coming from
water rather than a somebody's breathing
and coughing on you that's how i got
sick it was the water
no i don't know this snow but the two
main people then were pasteur and
beauchamp
beauchamp said it's not the bacteria
and it's it's the it's the terrain
now so essentially pasteur and his
colleagues
tried for 40 years and in fact it's very
interesting what happened then because a
german colleague named robert
koch came up with very simple
uh guidelines so that that we would know
whether
a microorganism is causing a disease
and it's very simple and straightforward
they're called coke's postulates
and they are the hallmark ever since of
how we prove
causation and it's very simple
you take up like a hundred sheep or a
hundred people with the same disease
and you identify an organism that's the
same
in all of those hundred people right
here's here's a way to think about this
i came up with this last night
if you had a disease called swollen
thumb syndrome
and so hundred people with swollen thumb
and you ask
them what happened to you and they said
i don't know if somebody came along and
bashed my thumb with a hammer
all hundred of them so that's turns out
not proof
uh so you go to next hundred people who
don't have a swollen phone and you say
um
did any of you bat get bashed with a
hammer no
none of us so that's postulate number
two
not no people who are healthy have that
organism
right because if they have it then why
didn't it make them sick
that's still not proof then he said you
have to take the organism
from the on from the sick people
isolate it purify it give it to the
unhealthy people
and if they get sick you prove causation
in other words you take the hammer bash
100 healthy people
and if they all get a swollen thumb
that's how human beings
understand causation every human being
would say
yes i'm sure that the hammer is what
causes them
and here's the trouble there is not coke
eventually said these postulates don't
work
because there's not one case in the
medical literature
where they've proven the postulates
not one we've looked for 20 years
they say they do they say they're still
valid because they're
common sense i have reports even from
this current episode
you know we see epidemiology somebody
should do cokes postulates
and then we have a report from this
current situation
coke's postulates were fulfilled but the
trouble is
they never isolated an organism they
never made an animal sick
and they didn't they didn't do coke's
postulates
so that's how this got started the next
okay go ahead go ahead so the next step
so so they failed to prove causation
with any bacteria
then they say well we have diseases now
which we can't find a bacteria
right but we know that must be an
infection
because it looks like it's contagious so
there must be something smaller than a
bacteria
and the main disease was polio so they
looked in the
dead dead brains in the spine they
looked for a bacteria they couldn't find
it
and so they said there must be something
smaller that's poisoning these children
and these people
and they called it a virus they didn't
see a virus they didn't know what they
were looking for they just said
there must be an infectious agent and so
then they said okay we're going to try
to isolate this because they were still
interested in these cokes postulates
and so they put it through a filter so
they had filters that could filter out
the bacteria in the cells
so they grant they took children or
people who had died of polio
they ground their brains up put it
through a filter
and then they took many many different
animals
and they fed them this filtrate and none
of them got sick
none of them and then they injected it
subcutaneously
into monkeys hamsters guinea pigs
you name it none of them got sick
and then they said something very
interesting which is
it turns out there's no animal model for
polio
which is a bizarre way to think because
what they're saying is we cannot
make an animal sick with this virus
filtrate
that we can't see and then in 1907 they
did the experiment that proved
virus sorry that polio was contagious
they took a child who had paralysis they
took a piece of their spine
they ground it up in a blender they
filtered it
and they took two monkeys i think they
were rhesus monkeys
drilled holes in their brains injected
about a half a cup of this stuff
into their brains one of the monkeys
died
one of the monkeys got paralyzed they
didn't do a control
in other words they didn't just inject a
half a cup of
you know water or something so they
don't know if the monkeys died because
monkeys don't like having a half a cup
of stuff injected right in their brain
maybe they had a herniation and they
held the monkey up
and they said see we proved polio is a
transmissible disease
now i don't know about you but i can see
you frowning there
that doesn't sound like science to me
so this entire study was based on two
monkeys two monkeys
the idea that polio was caused by a
filterable uh thing we couldn't see
right that's the studies now so we go on
from there then we go to 1918.
so now they say we've proven that
there's something
filterable right you know we got rid of
the bacteria we got rid of the cells
it could be a poison in there could be
arsenic
because it turns out that lead arsenic
and ddt
later caused the same symptoms as polio
and so they didn't know that or maybe
they did but they didn't ignored it
so they could even have had arsenic in
the in the water
but anyways because they didn't do a
control they have no idea
they can't find that out so then they go
to 1918
and about i don't know 20 million people
die from this spanish flu
highly contagious disease right
and then it you know they see one person
after another and again
epidemiology is not how science proves
causation
they only tell you you should look here
so they did the boston health department
did
study i have it said referenced in the
book i can read you the conclusion if
you want
they took about a hundred volunte 100
people
who had active symptoms of the spanish
flu
right this is killing millions of people
there snotty nose
coughing everything they got a hundred
volunteers
and they divided them into three groups
one group
they spent 10 minutes breathing as hard
as they could
into their mouth like
like that right into their open mouth 10
minutes yup
the other group they spent 10 to 15
minutes
coughing right in their face
and the other group they actually took
mucus
out of their nose right sucked the snot
out of their nose
and injected the snot right into the
volunteer's nose
these are a hundred people the boston
health department does this
and you know how many of these
volunteers got sick
one he got a runny nose which i have the
quote here
i could read it to you if you want that
says
it turns out that this that none of
these ways
uh are able to pass contain other
transmissible agent from one person to
another
now there you you can look at that and
you could say
that then they came to an interesting
conclusion patrick they said
it turns out we needed to be more
aggressive
in in exposing the volunteers
and i thought to myself when i read that
like what do a lung transplant or
something i mean
how can you be more aggressive than that
they cut they sucked the snot out and
injected
and literally one person who they said
this is not the flu
they just got a runny nose because we
ins injected some snot up their nose
uh i mean that's pretty intense i just i
just want to ask something if you can't
hold that thought because
so a hundred people
were tested this is a spanish flu era
1919.
1919 a third were asked to breathe 10
minutes
open mouth into somebody else's face
open mouth
open mouth yeah strong into their face
and then the other one was 10 or 15
minutes coughing into the face and the
last one was
taking mucus out and injected it into
the other person and only one out of a
hundred got sick
and had a runny nose not even sick right
so now here's my question for you so
then
based on what you're saying is is we
cannot
uh uh we cannot give our germ to
somebody else that's what you're saying
that that's not possible we cannot
i can't give my germ to somebody else is
that kind of what you're saying
no that is not what i'm saying because
what
what that that hasn't what that doesn't
prove you can't give
germs what it proves is you can't give
sickness to somebody else
okay then let me question you on that if
you can't there's a big difference there
patrick
right perfect that's good to know but i
i again for as a parent
this this is a epiphany moment i'd love
to have so
i have three kids you know the same once
one kid
gets sick everybody gets sick right or
you know
a parent gets sick when they have a baby
and they have a two-year-old kid in
their house
and then they get sick oh my gosh i'm
sick now my other son is sick now the
mom is sick and then at night when the
mom sleeps with the dad
then the dad is sick and that kind of
goes so that kind of
you know that argument kind of doesn't
uh
validate what happens in a lot of
families because when kids are around
other kids they tend to get sick
what would you say to that i would say
the same thing i would say
with every epidemiological observation
right you're talking epidemiology there
one person gets sick and then another
person gets sick
the same thing that happened to scurvy
the same thing that happened in spanish
flu
the same thing that happened with
anthrax the same thing
that's happened with polio now you have
to take that observation
and prove causation of a microbe
they did that over and over again and
they cannot prove
koch's postulates they cannot prove
causation
and all i would say now in the book
we did we do propose very specific
reasons why those observations might
happen
right so i i can i can
i i can explain exactly how you can
understand that event
i'd love to hear it go for it i'm all
right i think that comes later
okay because we still have to we we
you have to stick with the argument
which is
you have to take that observation right
and then isolate a virus or a bacteria
and prove that it can cause that disease
they've tried that for 150 years
and they can't prove it
in fact they can't demonstrate it so you
know we don't know if there's some sort
of similar
toxic exposure in your house whether
there's some sort of resonance phenomena
you know like
if you put 10 young women in a in a
cabin for six months they all start
menstruating at the same time
you can't there's no virus there
so we can you can see physiological
responses
happen for lots of reasons and
in order to show that it's a microbe you
have to go
through the steps and they try over and
over again
and i can keep going if you want and see
how they try
and it turns out it's not the micro
i i also understand patrick how bizarre
this may seem to people because they get
stuck on the epidemiology they get stuck
on this observation this observation has
been around for thousands of years
same with scurvy same with lots of
things
it turns out we have a scientific method
to prove it
we looked and it turns out that's not
the cause
so what is
well i just said basically these
phenomena
are elimination of toxins so the trouble
is we're skipping ahead here
and i would rather go back and see how
the virus theory actually
came here here's what what i'd like to
challenge you to do
challenge my challenge to you would be
try to explain it to a
six-year-old to understand who's not in
your world and doesn't fully understand
all the technical terms
speak to me as if the average person is
listening to the saying you know what
doc i really want to learn
but i don't understand how this is even
possible if
you know based on what i've experienced
and what i've been told my entire life
with visiting doctors this is what i've
seen so if you can explain that and
pack it into a fairly short amount of
time to the best of your abilities i'd
love to hear that perspective from you
so here here's some facts about what
we're calling a
cold or a sickness right
so essentially what happens is
you so you're well and then
you usually get a fever or some other
symptom
and then after that what happens is you
get a runny nose
or mucus or cough or some sort of snot
happens
and then what happens is you're better
and in fact when we do the the
studies of what happens for instance
with a child with chickenpox right
so childhood chickenpox once they go
through those stages
it turns out they're better for life
meaning they have less asthma they have
less eczema
they have less cancer they have less
osteoarthritis
they have less heart disease all these
are clearly
in the medical literature now here's
another one and i wrote a whole book
on the cancer about this it turns out
that the most reliable way to treat
cancer
and this was done with coley's toxins
and it was done in the 1920s
is if somebody has cancer and they get a
fever because they supposedly have an
infection then they have a much better
outcome and some of them are even cured
of the cancer
in other words this process that you're
calling getting sick
is simply a detoxification reaction
so in other words you poison somebody
with whatever
it could be emotional poison it could be
bad
food it could be toxins in the house it
could be that we're all exposed to
glyphosate
it could be that we're all exposed to
electromagnetic fields
all of these things distort our the gels
in our cells
and then the body has to flush them out
it does this through making fever making
mucus
we call that infectious disease and it
turns out it's just a detoxification
reaction
and the the thing about it is when you
treat it like that
you get people who have no bad outcomes
and are better for life that's what's
happening
now there's something even very
interesting about this because
we now know from very clear scientific
studies
that if you poison a cell or a tissue
it it breaks down into little packages
of genetic material
which are called exosomes as a method of
detoxification
in other words it's similar to how a
tree does if you
if you have a beetles eating a tree they
send out signals to tell all the other
trees
that there's been something happening
that's that's noxious in their area
and then the other trees make a
defensive response
now i'm aware that this may be more than
a six-year-old can do
but i'm trying my best to to be as clear
as i can here
so what what's happening then is
one child has a starts the process
and then they send out this signal to
the other children and
even maybe the parents you should make a
defensive detoxification reaction
unfortunately we misinterpret that as
sickness
we even misinterpret that the body makes
these
these detoxification packages that are
called
exosomes which are mistaken for viruses
and they're not contagious they're not
infectious
they're how the body communicates what's
happened
and detoxifies so can i ask you
simple questions okay and simple answers
let's see if we can pull this off
so doc how do i get sick
do i get sick through respiratory
do i get sick through water i drink do i
get sick through the food i eat do i get
sick through the way i think
how does one get sick there's basically
four mechanisms of getting sick one
injuries right you fall off a cliff and
break your leg
that's a kind of sickness number two
starvation
that's like scurvy that's like barry
berry that's like pellegra
you don't have the nutrients you you
don't have enough collagen you don't
have enough vitamin c
so that the tissues start to break down
and they excrete these poisons
to essentially try to detoxify
so number one injury number two uh
starvation
and then three which is the biggest is
uh you're poisoned so in other words
just like the milk example you poison
the milk
the bacteria come and eat the poison
and it's the same argument as if
if you think because the bacteria are
there they're the cause of the problem
that's like saying you go to a town and
you see fires and then you see firemen
there
and so the firemen must be causing the
fires
actually the firemen are there to clean
up the fires
and put out the fires out the bacteria
are there
to biodegrade dead and dying tissue
so why is it dead and dying because it's
been poisoned
with what i mean you want me to knit we
each of us have 120
carcinogenic chemicals in our blood and
urine and all mother's milk does
we're exposed to electromagnetic fields
which we have
1200 studies that show that they do harm
glyphosate is in the air air pollution
cyanide there's lots of ways people are
poisoned
and the final one is we have emotional
toxicity or poisoning
uh or i sometimes say the way we think
because if you think in this way
that the world is out to get you that
that instead of this the world is a
cooperative venture
that's really the model that i'm trying
to bring here
the world is a cooperative venture it's
not this
survival of the fittest model that was
just a construct
once you see it like that that's that's
the terrain theory
that's i i have a healthy terrain
and i'm resistant to sickness so four
ways we get sick
injuries starvation which is scurvy bury
bury
this is when you're not getting enough
nutrients collagen three is poison
similar to the story of the milk and
fourth one is emotional toxicity
uh the world is not out there to get you
it's a collab collaborative efforts and
uh if you look at the world in a
different way you won't get sick so if i
were to ask you
when's the last time you got patrick let
me let me just interrupt for a minute
because when you look at it if you
permit me when you look at how we
prove viral viruses are contagious
or in our pathogenic that's not
contagious
let me change that word so how does a
modern virologist
prove a virus is contagious let me go
through the steps
so you take somebody who's sick like
your child with
with chickenpox right and you take some
of the mucus from that child
and then you centrifuge it which is not
purification
right so you have all kinds of cells and
stuff
in there and you don't have a pure virus
and then you take that tissue and you
and i'm sorry you take that
stuff right the mucus and you inoculate
that on a tissue
like a monkey kidney cell or a fetal
skin cell
or an immortalized lung cancer cell
right you take that unpurified stuff
and you inoculate it on a tissue and see
whether it grows
and kills the tissue you with me sure
now it doesn't and and that was the
problem of virology
so they figured out that they had to
starve the tissue
and poison it with antibiotics and
oxidizing agents and only then would the
so-called virus
kill the tissue and that's how they
prove that the viruses kill the tissue
and then they get this material from the
breakdown of the tissue
and they say see the virus kill the
tissue and
the reason i say that is because it's
the exact same model as how we get sick
they starve and poison the tissue just
like we're starved and poisoned
and then we break down and create these
particles
which are unfortunately called
contagious viruses
so what was your point of going where
you just went right
now when i was explaining the four
reasons why you stated to me why people
get sick why did you go there i'm
curious
i went there because there's this
interesting correlation
between how virologists
prove viral causation
and in the exact correlation with my
theory my proposal with how human beings
and animals get sick
starvation and poison that's how they
make
viruses kill cells so when's the last
time you got sick
i don't remember you don't remember i
don't remember
written like it's been decades well not
decades
years okay so you don't get sick
i got sick every once in a while
interesting
and when you do get sick are you the
kind that's curious to find out how you
got sick or very rarely do you find out
why you got sick it's very difficult in
any one
sick particular person to find out
what the starvation or poisoning or
or inciting event was now but that's
what i spent my career
trying to find out what happened to
people
okay so let's let's uh uh let's
transition
let's transition to a different topic
here and i hope all the doctors that
listen to you they probably learned the
rest of us
we may we may be lost right now we were
trying to track with you but
your level of uh uh the level you're
explaining this stuff i'm trying to get
the viewers to understand to the
simplest
possible way let's let's talk about
something we all deal with
okay let's talk about something that we
all deal with and maybe this will be
a different angle we can take heart we
are told
heart is genetics it comes from your mom
and dad
and you know every time i go to the
doctor to ask me a question
did your mom have a heart attack no how
about your dad my dad has 13 heart
attacks really yes
how old was his first one 44 how many
has he had 13
has he had an open heart surgery yes
does he have stents
yes three of them how many angiograms
he's had six angiograms six
angioplastics you gotta be careful
because you may have it right
so what they don't know is my dad smoked
cigarettes two packs a day for 30 years
and he drank a full glass of alcohol
every single day
for 30 years is what he did i don't
smoke i don't drink so
what is the cause of heart disease and
why heart attacks take place
so you know we're going to execute
just remember just remember sixth grade
sixth grade simplified for us
all right i'm trying i'm trying my best
patrick um
first of all uh here's you know we have
to base
every answer i give i want it to be
based on
fat right observations and fat so
fact number one in 1920
in this country there was almost no
heart disease
everybody acknowledges that in fact
there's an interesting story that a guy
invented the ekg at harvard medical
school offered it to the harvard faculty
and they said there's no use for this
there's no heart disease in this country
and whenever traditional indigenous
people are studied
they have no evidence of heart disease
they have no evidence of dying of heart
attacks
now i don't know about your concept of
genetics but we're talking
two or three generations ago we went
from
almost nobody having heart attacks and
by the way
if you look at a cookbook from 1920 and
you say what were the healthiest foods
that people should eat it was very clear
butter lard and eggs and cream
nobody had heart attacks the fact that
now in 1940
just one generation later it became the
number one
killer of americans there is no possible
way that has anything to do with
genetics
see now i got smarter tom
i'm telling you what a difference it
made in the first 45 minutes and now i'm
telling you
that was ridiculous so 1920
no heart disease just two or three
generations ago in a 1920 cookbook
they're talking about butter lard and
eggs in 1940 a generation later they're
calling that the number one killer
so who wrote the 1940 cookbooks and who
made us think that these things kill us
with heart attacks and then when do we
start having heart attacks
we started having heart attacks with the
two
major things happen one the major
change in the american diet again away
from healthy fats
and towards margarine crisco and other
processed foods three things two
the second thing was the widespread use
of chemicals in agriculture and
food and ddt and all the rest of it
and three was the increasing
electrification of the earth
which we now know interferes with your
ability to generate
uh oxygen and to use oxygen so as soon
as those thing
three things happen you see this
epidemic this epidemic of heart disease
now here here's another thing patrick
you know
if you ask a hundred doctors a hundred
lay people
100 people off the street why do people
have heart attacks
right they say the exact same thing you
have these three major coronary arteries
they carry all the blood to your heart
one of them gets blocked with plaque
or two of them or three of them the
blood can't get through
and then you have a heart attack and die
right
sure everybody knows that yep you're
with me i'm with you
this part i'm with you sixth grade fully
qualified got it
okay now let's dissect this out a little
bit
uh i've seen probably a hundred people
come to my office
say 50 year old man uh
let me stop for a minute here let me go
back a little bit
so would you agree that if there's
something blocking your arteries
it's probably in your blood
sure right second question
do you think the blood in your art and
your coronary arteries the heart
arteries is the same blood as you have
in your spleen
and liver and foot and everywhere else i
would assume so
yes i would too okay so the blood
leading to your spleen
has whatever it is that's causing the
plaque just like
in the coronary arteries so you must get
plaque in your splenic artery
as well right sure yes
now how many people have you heard of
who've had spleen attacks
i've never heard of spleen attacks so i
i've given lectures to maybe
50 to 100 000 people in my career
one of the questions if i'm talking
about heart please raise your hand
if you've heard of anybody or know of
anybody
who had a spleen attack a liver attack a
foot attack or a kidney attack
you know how many people raised their
hands none none
now next question how many of you know
somebody personally or
in the news who had a heart attack
plenty 100
sure how come
same arteries same blood same plaque
how come next question
guy comes to me i've seen this probably
uh 50 times
maybe a hundred times because i wrote a
book about the heart i have a medicine
yeah people come to me 50 year old guy
doc i walked up a hill i felt a little
pressure in my chest
i went to the doctor he said oh you
might have heart disease we gotta
check your arteries does an angiogram
says you have a 95
blockage usually they go like this and
if you block any more you're gonna die
of a heart attack
right i've heard that a hundred times
let's think about this for a minute
we're told that all the blood to your
heart goes through those three arteries
right sure that's why they unblock them
you not you but the guy who came to me
if you have five percent blood flow
through your artery
okay how did you walk up that hill
next question you mean if you not you
but that guy you block from five percent
to three percent
that's gonna kill you
i don't believe it five percent is no
blood flow
three percent five percent exactly the
same
there is no evidence that that makes any
difference at all
next thing there was the biggest study
ever done
on people who died of heart attacks they
did it with autopsies
a guy named giorgio baroldi what year
was it
what what year was it
2000 something so this is recent it's
not our twenties or forty it's a recent
this is 2010
if you want to read the entire book if
you're a glutton for scientific
punishment go to
heart attack new dot com at the bottom
there's a print version
parolee prints the whole version does
autopsies 50 years on people who die of
heart attacks
he says 41 of them have a blocked arter
and of that blockage fifty percent come
after the heart attack not before
so if you do the math that means that
eighty percent of the heart attacks
have are have no evidence of any
blockage
in the in the artery leading to that
part of the heart
none now the when i wrote the book i
pointed that out
and said what is the reason why these
other 80
die and in fact if you look at the
studies of stents
and bypasses right so these are
mechanisms or strategies to
clear out the arteries if it was just a
blockage it should work
every single one of them the conclusion
is there's no evidence
that having a stent makes you live
longer or
not have a second heart attack and then
in october 2018
in the lancet for the first time they
did a
blinded study of stents right so they
took
i don't know how many i think 70 people
who had a
single vessel blockage right
half of them they put a stent in the
other half they put a catheter in they
told them they put a stent in but didn't
and they assessed them eight weeks later
they had the exact same amount of chest
pain
so not in the headlines of the article
was
stents proven useless now
it's therefore proven that stents don't
prevent
further heart attacks they don't make
you live longer
and they don't help you have less chest
pain
and so it's very difficult to say so
what is the benefit
and i can't think of any and in the
article they said
there must be something else that is
causing people to have heart attacks
and essentially then the european heart
association
redid their typology of heart disease
and said 60 to 80 percent of people who
have heart disease
signs and symptoms have no evidence of
any plaque buildup so essentially the
whole plaque thing
at most it has to do with 20 percent
and the fact of the matter is most of
the blood flow to our heart
doesn't come from this these arteries
anyways
that it it is basically a watershed with
millions of little capillaries
just like a watershed instead of a river
and when you have disease in how you
generate energy
then you have a heart attack
so what do you what do you do now to uh
prevent from having a heart attack like
you know a basic question for you where
somebody could apply right off the bat
when you order food
what foods do you absolutely avoid uh
it's it so i i interpret questions as
you can see
you have to forgive me uh so here's
another way to ask that
tom should i read labels right
that's that's another way to ask that
sure tom's answer
no if it has a label don't eat it
in other words in other words you go to
the store
or you go to a market or you go to a
tree and you see that's an apple
you don't need a label that's a fish
or here's another way to say that we
know that
the people in 1920 didn't have heart
attacks
eat what they ate they had bacon and
eggs for breakfast
the bacon was on pasture-raised pigs
because if you keep a feet a pig in
confinement
it will become toxic and then it will
quote get infected so that's helpful
right there what you just said is
helpful pasture-raised pigs
right right pasture-raised pigs cows
that are on
pasture so that they have all the
healthy nutrients
and then freshly ground wheat that you
bake into sourdough bread
and vegetables from your garden and if
it has a label don't eat it
and i didn't say don't eat processed
food
because like making bacon is processed
or eating sauerkraut and here's another
thing patrick
if you go back to your traditional
iranian diet from two generations ago
number one they didn't have heart
disease number two they probably lived
long healthy lives
and number three they ate exactly what i
described
i think i'm gonna move into that forest
right behind you and learn how to hunt
and just live there that's why i forget
about this business stuff
i don't know what i'm putting myself
through doc i might just go and live in
the forest learn how to hunt
live like they lived before and live a
couple hundred years you don't have to
do that all you have to do is
go and get nourishing traditions and get
my heart booked
and follow the guidelines fair enough so
we'll do that and we'll put the link
below also we'll put the link below to
the article you
asked for uh you suggested with uh the
gentleman
on the bottom of that website we'll put
that link below as well that was very
helpful
here's the next question for you next
question for you recently
a lot of my friends uh wives
specifically are telling me they're
having a lot of vertigo
and they're getting dizzy okay and this
isn't just one or two i'm talking like
these are close friends of mine very
they're all executives and successful
business people
and they're saying i'm getting vertigo
i'm getting you know dizzy i've never
had vertigo i don't know why i'm getting
dizzy
then they go to the doctor and the
doctor tells them you know hold your
head the whole exercise what you need to
do and do this and do that and
one of them went to another doctor in
idaho i believe
and the doctor came back and said you
know there's a couple things that's
going on it's called
electrosensitivity i'm sure you've heard
of electrosensitivity
and bbc even did an article on this
saying i didn't believe people had it
and then it happened to me
uh uh which is you know folks who are
feeling
certain things diagnosis based on 5g
this is a bbc article
saying i didn't believe it people had it
then it happened to me close fatigue
pain headaches dizziness burning
twitching nausea palpitations just some
of the symptoms experienced by people
who say
they suffer from electrosensitivity uh
uh
these are most self-diagnosed years of
cancer anyways on the bottom it says the
world health organization says
electrosensitivity is not a medical
diagnosis and both the
world health organization and public
health england say there's no scientific
basis that these symptoms are linked
to electromagnetic field exposure such
as 5g
you know you hear some people say yes
you hear some people say no
what are your thoughts of any linkage
between this
a vertigo and dizziness and 5g towers
being put up in different places
vertigo and dizziness has been a symptom
of
electromagnetic field poisoning for at
least 120 years
every time there's a increase in the
electrical
activity on the earth millions of people
get vertigo dizziness lightheadedness
and there's a very clear reason for that
which basically goes into the water
which i think
is probably going to be too technical
but it basically destructures the water
we have very clear evidence of this
and that creates the experience of
altered electrical activity because
after all we're electrical beings
and anybody who says oh there's no
evidence that we're electrical beings i
just
say have you ever heard of an ekg or an
eeg
these are measuring electrical
wavelengths in your brain
and your heart and you can also
demonstrate
that you can have abnormal electrical
activity by an eeg
with exposure to cell phones you can do
a mitigation device
and so you can mitigate that and the
abnormal electrical activity will go
away
and the vertigo and dizziness will be
gone
the world health organization is wrong
there's approximately 1200
peer-reviewed studies in the literature
documenting the health consequence
of exposure to electromagnetic fields
what he says otherwise is simply not
aware of the science uh two questions
for you one
uh what is a mitigation device that you
said could prevent that from happening
there's a there's a number of them
there's one uh
system called biogeometry and there's
another system that uses scalar waves
which basically
you know the problem with
electromagnetic fields if i could put it
in context
please is humans evolved
to to experience and utilize the
electromagnetic energy of
the sun and the moon and the earth and
plants
and rocks and minerals and and water and
every living thing
that is the energy of life and it's all
in this pattern that's that's very sort
of chaotic
it's not it's not one wavelength over
and over and over again
in fact if you do a if you do a
measurement of the sun
you get no pulsations it's just a
continuous sheet of a variety of
electromagnetic fields
i don't know if this is too complicated
but a little bit complicated but i'm
trying to up my
intelligence so keep going okay so
that's normal
and then you say i want to use a
frequency to have an effect
like a radio so i don't want all of
these frequencies
i just want 98.6
so i one frequency and so you get a
frequency
and you make it intense so that somebody
can pick it up with a receiver
now the problem is that's functional
and then we have sound called radio or a
radar or millimeter waves or
wireless devices they all work on these
very consistent high intensity
frequencies
the problem is they're toxic to the
tissues
all of them because this is not
something that human beings or any
living thing
has ever been exposed to and so it
creates a defensive
response which is to change the
electrical activity
hence you experience that as vertigo and
dizziness
that's an electrical activity the nerves
are electrical
devices so to speak so you you poison
the electrical mechanism of a human
being
and then you your experience of that is
vertigo
now uh so so that's the problem
but what's the solution well
the solution there's one of two
one is don't do that right
if we're meant to be to live with
with non-pulsating high intensity
frequency waves then it seems a little
crazy to keep doing that
over and over again and expect that
we're going to get away with it
so that's one solution unfortunately or
fortunately depending on how you look at
it
people don't like that solution sure
they don't want to do that
so there are people who are looking at
creating
interference patterns or this actually
works through the water in your tissues
so if you strengthen the water it will
be more resistant to that that's the
terrain
if you allow these fields to poison the
water
they break down the bacteria eat it they
excrete viruses
and then you think you have an infection
uh
so no i i don't want to get into naming
a product here because i'm not here to
sell
but no you don't need to name a product
but what i'm asking you is are there
products for people to use who
are dealing with vertical and dizziness
due to electrosensitivities and if
yes is that something that's over the
counter that i can find
yes okay is there something they call it
not even a brand is there is there
something they call it or no well
one method it's a method is biogeometry
that's one method okay and another is to
use scalar waves
scale our waves okay there's different
it's basically just putting an
interference pattern into the into your
surrounding
atmosphere if somebody searches those
two things can they find it out for
themselves if this is
a matter because the people that are
calling me this is really bothering them
a lot
if they wanted to do research is this
something easily to be found the
biogeometry and the scalar waves
yes but i would again patrick i'm not
going to get into
endorsing products i'm not saying that
what all i'm asking you is if i go
research it is it easy for me to find it
to go uh uh uh use some of the uh
process that's out there is it easy to
find for myself
yes but you may end up getting something
that doesn't work
because there's scale our ways and then
there's people who really know how to do
it just like everything in the world
there's
apples and then there's really good
apples and there's
meat and there's really good meat and is
there a way to differentiate between the
bs and the real
uh real product to use or whatever waves
it is to use
so here i'm going to get a little
self-serving and so
people have to understand that i have
spent
35 to 40 years researching this and
using it with my thousands of patients
to see what works
because i can't afford to use things
that don't work
right that's my career okay so
we wrote about them in the book okay all
right then
which book is it in by the way is it uh
contagious which is coming out september
29th okay as long as it's in there
there's nothing wrong with putting a
plug into your book by the way that's
good to go
okay that was very helpful let's go to
the next topic this was actually very
helpful next topic stem cells okay what
you're seeing happening a lot is a lot
of people are starting to talk about
stem cells and what i mean by i live in
dallas
okay somebody has a back problem
somebody has
knee problems joints shoulder they'll
tell you go get stem cell shots
and 35 million stem cells or whatever
these
procedures cost between 10 to 40 000
depending on what kind of stem cell is
it your own
is it somebody else is it from bone
marrow is it how much
research have you done on stem cells and
how much credence or credibility
do you give to the fact that these stem
cell shots can really help somebody
heal and even feel younger so i am not
an expert on
stem cells so i i really don't even want
to comment on that
um but one of the reasons is is because
i think that the whole conception of
what osteoarthritis or joint disease is
is incorrect and so for me
there was essentially no reason to need
to use stem cells
because once one understands why
somebody has an arthritic joint
then you can resolve the problem without
having to resort to five million dollars
worth of
stem cells which you know again i
haven't looked into it enough to know
okay fair enough i think that's good let
me ask another one i mean if you don't
have an opinion on these things we'll
just skip and you can just say pat i
don't have any
opinion i have an opinion but pat i have
an opinion on
arthritis and i have a treatment and a
conception of how
somebody can heal from arthritis so that
they don't need to spend money on stem
cells
i'd love to hear because people look my
dad has arthritis i know a lot of people
that have arthritis and it's
it's a very annoying uh thing to have so
if you don't mind taking a minute i'm
sure some people would like to hear it
so and again with everything with me is
you have to understand the basics and i
i i can sense that it's getting a little
bit annoying
no i kind of know where you're gonna go
now observation facts so please
lead the way with observation in fact
okay so what is a joint a joint is a
bone
and then it has a structured water
encasement that we call a bursa
and there's two bursas that oppose each
other right
that's what we call a joint now if you
look into the science of structured
water
you find that all structured water is
negatively charged
and so what happens in a joint is you
have these two negatively charged
jello structures that because they're
negatively charged they oppose each
other
and repel each other and create smooth
movement of the joint
right that's a normal joint now what
happens
is if you destructure the water in other
words make it into
more liquid water instead of jello water
it a loses its charge and b
loses its ability to repel each other
and
gradually gets worn away more and more
until you have bone on bone and then you
have to get a knee replacement
the problem is the loss of structure of
the gels surrounding your knees so then
you have to say
how do we make gels in the first place
the same sorry the same way we make
jello
you take proteins in this case collagen
you take healthy unpolluted water
i gotta tell you i've never had a doctor
recommend that eating more jello is good
for you but i'm glad you were able to do
that i'm sure a lot of us are excited
about that
yeah it's not jello because jello has
all kinds of stuff in it
i'm talking about collagen proteins i'm
giving you a hard time
see and you stop poisoning the
the structure of the water it can form
properly and then you're fine
and that's how i did medicine and
see for some people this is theory you
know
for me i had to figure out a way to help
people
rebuild their their knee because they
were in pain and they were didn't like
it
and i didn't want to give them drugs and
interestingly the anti-inflammatory the
inflammation
is how you remodel the joint and
if you use anti-inflammatories like
advil or aleve we know that it makes the
joint worse
it also destructures your jello so i was
about
recreating the healthy conditions for
your joint
and then i have people say yeah now like
my knee doesn't hurt anymore
and they didn't have to get stem cells
and they didn't have to get a knee
replacement
and they stopped poisoning you know
again electromagnetic fields
destructure your gels and that's another
reason why you don't have a healthy knee
okay let's go to the next topic that was
good that was helpful here's the next
one since we have you here
i read a book called ageless man ageless
man and the author in this book talks
about the fact that
uh as man ages when their testosterone
level
drops their temper goes higher their
bitterness goes higher
they can't uh conduct in the same
old methods they used to in the bedroom
when they used to make movies in a
bedroom now they can barely make a short
film
uh you know their joints hurt their body
hurts and because testosterone levels
are
low many different ways they're not
benefiting from uh from that
so you you see a lot of people out there
nowadays
not doctors but i'm hearing this a lot
i'm curious to know what you say about
this i've had a lot of bodybuilders on
but you hear a lot of people saying
testosterone replacement
meaning a form of taking some kind of
steroids
or some kind of growth hormone when you
get past the age of 40 or 50
can actually help you live a longer life
where you become
ageless okay now i'm curious to know
somehow i have an idea what direction
you're going to go with your answer
but i'm curious to know what you have to
say regarding some form of steroids to
increase your testosterone level
what are your thoughts on that so again
i i can't answer i mean i could say
that's not what i
do but that doesn't help anybody i think
it would be better if i explain
why i don't like that approach is that
okay
sure so the problem is what's the
therapy and what's the disease
and here's the situation because of a
whole variety of things
maybe just including aging but poisoning
and starvation and the rest
your your tissues are breaking down
and you experience that as dysfunction
right and you can't perform in the
bedroom you don't feel as good you're
irritable etc
now there's there's two ways of
understanding this
one of the things that deteriorates is
your testosterone
and so that's the disease right here's
another way of understanding
you have crappy tissue and so
because my body is smarter than you are
it's going to lower the testosterone to
protect you from hurting yourself
because you're in no
shape to go you know do anything
because you don't have good joints your
your body is deteriorating
so i'm going to lower my your
testosterone level
to protect you
and the question is which one of those
two is correct
because i think what's happening is your
body is
lowering the testosterone as a
protective mechanism
to keep you from hurting yourself now
the reason i think that's true
is i take that person who's falling
apart
and i say look pat stop falling apart
feed yourself good food get out of the
wi-fi
stop poisoning yourself and you know
what happens
your testosterone levels go up why
now we're good now i'm not so worried
about hurting yourself
and so i self-regulate
and the problem is if you start giving
somebody testosterone
they become an adult because they then
down
regulate and they make less and less and
then
if you ever stop because you give them
cancer or something they are screwed big
time
and so my way is is honoring the wisdom
of the body
saying this is not a disease this is a
a strategy it's a protective response
to the fact that you're just not taking
care of yourself
you're eating crappy food your joints
are deteriorating
if i were you i would lower your
testosterone too
keep you from hurting yourself my gosh
what a
so i would lower your testosterone too
keep you from hurting yourself what do
you mean lower my testosterone level to
keep me from hurting myself
so i just said so you're you're you're
you have this
you haven't uh you want men's marriage
to not work out how many more divorces
do you want to see i mean you know
what's going on
you got that wrong killing us we got
some men we want to keep these guys
married i don't want our
audience to get 92 divorces tomorrow and
blame me for it
but pat what i said was you will end up
with
higher testosterone so a wi-fi diet is
what i need is what you're saying
no what you need to do is is if you
deteriorate right because you're not
feeding yourself
you're not living as you should right
then your body isn't it's the same
reason why
women who starve young women who starve
themselves
they lose their periods that's not a
disease
that's protecting them from getting
pregnant
because they don't have the nourishment
and the health to
carry a healthy baby very interesting
analogy yes if you're
a sick guy because you're not you know
eating right and living right
yeah you lower your hormone levels now i
didn't say
to keep lowering them i said if you
nourish yourself
your body will naturally raise the
testosterone level
and then you will have a healthy
marriage and a healthy life
and all those things you said so you
can't blame me
for the divorce because i i
give you a very specific way
of raising it without rate without doing
anything
except working with how your body
actually functions
okay so okay fine okay let's go a little
deeper on this topic but in a different
angle so
i think it's fair to say that i'm never
going to see by you winning mr olympia
bodybuilding champion is that a fair
assessment
wait say that again is it fair to say
that you will never win a bodybuilding
contest
is that a fair assessment okay i just
want to make sure i want to go based on
facts and observations is what i want to
do
i want to respect you so so let me ask
you this when i was in my 20s
i could eat a burger or i could eat a
cheese
you know a pizza and nothing would
happen to me the moment i turned 30
that same pizza i ate i felt a little
bit heavier right
in my 30s i was still pretty flexible
and then when i hit 40 my flexibility
wasn't the same as it was in my 30s i
could still do the splits until 28 29
i can't do the splits obviously today at
but when i go do my yoga classes it's
not the same when i talk to people in
their 50s
they say you may pay a visit to the
doctor to
ask him about cialis or or what's the
other one
uh uh cialis or uh give me a break it's
the other famous one it's uh
uh viagra cialis viagra so
what is is there a natural cialis or
viagra
you seem like somebody that would know
the answer to that question there's a
lot of people that would want to know
the answer to a natural
method of increasing my testosterone
level to uh
bring out the ron jeremy esque of mine
in the bedroom
it's very simple patrick and that the
risk of sounding like a broken record
you the the the native americans had a
very good formula for this
number one they ate healthy fats they
moved around a lot and they ate the
organ meats of the buffalo
particularly the testes and the adrenal
gland
and if you the problem is
the the the lowering of your sex drive
the lowering of your
libido is your body saying
hat if you're going to poison yourself
and starve yourself your whole life
i'm going to not have you make babies
because you're
too dumb to do that
so the mechanism is lowering your
testosterone what a way of looking at it
though let me tell you that's that's
very very uh interesting way of looking
at it on what you're saying right there
it's accurate and the reason i know it's
accurate
is i tell okay you come to me or you did
and i say patrick stop doing those
eat the way that people supposed to eat
take care of your water eat some you
know organ preparations i'll tell you
where to get them
and your sex drive and all these things
and flexibility will come back
and you didn't have to take any drugs
and poison yourself
worse and this is not a theory
patrick this is what i've been doing for
35 years
so what do i to be successful
where do i get some high quality uh
buffalo balls
i mean i could tell you the product but
i didn't want to
come here and and sound like i'm selling
anybody any product
but i have spent 35 years trying to find
out
who knows how to make buffalo balls and
i found out so you're going to reveal it
or is it a secret that you're just going
to keep for you and your family i mean
this like
i'm sure you've shared it with joseph
your son what what is the buffalo ball
formula here
go to dr tom cowan dot com you'll see
a formula called mail optimization
and a bunch of secrets with you let me
tell you oh my gosh
it's not secret i don't want to i i'm
here to help people with information you
give us we're going to go to the website
we're going to put the link below can
you give us a glimpse for people that
are here to give them an idea they're
still going to go to your site
we'll drive them to it is there any
hints you can give us
about what about this buffalo balls like
where we can get them called
mail optimization formula so is it a
medicine i would take or i would go to
store to buy it
you can get it on our website okay all
right so we'll drive it to your website
as well
you know when you combine marketing and
doctor and research you
find yourself a doctor tom cowan so it's
a very very interesting combination
right there
you know the rest of us are trying to
figure out marketing you already have it
down so
final thoughts here before we wrap up is
coronavirus uh we're seeing cases coming
down
we're seeing that's coming down we're
seeing numbers are looking better
uh we're seeing you know election year
that's coming up and a lot of people are
right now talking about vaccines and
you know president trump is talking
about how
he's shooting to have a vaccine
available by you know
november 1st you're seeing some people
that are not confident about it they're
not comfortable about it
we haven't yet talked anything about
covid what are your thoughts with covet
and
coronavirus what's taking place there
and when the vaccine does come out
are you someone that trusts taking a
vaccine or there's no way in the world
you're going to touch a vaccine
so given the that we're basically at the
end of our time
for me to get into the whole coronavirus
thing
now i think would be a little bit
out of context let me just say that we
wrote a whole book about
this and we go through the science of
whether
there's evidence that covet 19 is caused
by
coronavirus all i will say
is we present the evidence in the book
that there is no possible way that
covet 19 is caused by this coronavirus
all of the tasks are meaningless all of
the numbers are meaningless
any vaccine for a coronavirus can't
possibly be
at be you know true or valid
because until it's proven that
coven 19 is caused by this virus
which it hasn't been and i know that for
a fact and anybody who wants to
go into the details should read our book
the contagion myth
so all these questions are essentially
moot about
cases there's no test that shows
you know reliably whether there's a case
or not
and i don't expect anybody to believe
that
all i want them to do is look at the
evidence we lay out the evidence in the
book
and i think the evidence will stand for
itself
i think that's a good way to wrap up the
interview we're going to put the link
below to your latest book that's coming
out september 29 2020 depending on when
you watch it you can go in the
description and order the book for
yourself
uh dr tom cowan
thank you so much for your time i've
enjoyed it
we started off in the interview at the
beginning extremely technical
we went then speaking to sixth graders
and then we finished speaking to
year olds and then we finished speaking
of 50 year olds so i think we've covered
it all we've spoken to educated people
business people sales people younger
people everybody someone's going to get
something
out of this interview and again thank
you for making the time to be a guest on
valuetainment
all right patrick take care it's good to
meet you and talk to you
likewise thank you so we have a lot of
different types of yes but this doctor
had a different approach to the way he
uh
viewed heart disease germs
i mean even ed that we talked about
testosterone stem cells was very
interesting kirsten know what you took
away from it
if you want to comment below if you
enjoyed this interview and never seen
the debate that i had between alan
dershowitz
and bobby kennedy robert kennedy jr over
the topic of vaccines click over you to
watch that and if you've not subscribed
to the channel
please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye